let's say you have no races let's say
you have no classes no nothing there's
no purpose in your life you know people
need to have purpose to get up they need
purpose to
perform you need to get to a point in
your life where there's nothing on the
docket there's no 5K there's no I'm
going to get into school to be this or
that and still perform to the highest
level if you're not constantly
performing without purpose you're not
going to be ready when the time comes
it's this magical thing purpose that
we're all looking for but what's funny
about it all is that we need these
things to perform but we don't take a
second to realize the purpose is always
there the purpose never leaves us
because the very purpose is you you are
always the purpose